don't engage them because if you engage
them they come to you they need a
operating they know this is not the way
a highly restrictive 21 day lockdown is
supposed to work
a solitary policeman screaming and
pleading with thousands of people to
spread themselves out a leg Xandra
Township is badly overcrowded and the
coronavirus will do great damage but
people need to eat the South African
government has ordered everyone to stay
at home although individuals can go to
the shops to buy food but it's not
supposed to work like this we are out
now going to make shopping you see we
are meeting different people if I'm
infected maybe this man is not infected
I'm spreading and spreading the virus
today people is not gonna like
we saw no social distancing no masks no
sanitizer and one policeman in charge
not easy not easy
the experts fear a catastrophe as kovat
19 spreads through South Africa the
township residents took little notice of
the government's new rules as the day
wore on the Army moved in and we watched
as they were heckled and cheered from
Alexandra's alleyways shut down shops
and to try and get people to stay in
their homes and their shacks but the
problem is these troops are completely
outnumbered here there just aren't
enough of them this lockdown is stripped
anyone caught outside their home faces
six months in jail but it's not taken
seriously here people sharing one room
shacks are not going to stay inside the
residence Abbadon flowed around the
troops who were given a mission they
could not complete the soldiers began to
lose their patience we saw one man
kicked and punched for standing outside
it was a demonstration not of strength
but weakness for this Township and many
others cannot be policed and its
residents will not self isolate as the
virus advances they are running a
terrible risk John sparks Sky News
Johannesburg